hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
long-time listeners and readers of my
books and things like that will know
that i have a
very deep interest in time in what time
is
the physics of it but also how it floats
into our everyday lives right we human
beings
use time all the time as it were
and so that hooks up with another
frequent interest of us here on the
podcast which is
neuroscience how the brain works and how
the brain thinks about things
so there's no better person to talk to
about this stuff than today's guest
dean wanamano who is a neuroscientist at
ucla
who specializes in how the brain tells
time how the brain
thinks about time he's the author of two
books one is called
brain bugs how the brain's flaws shape
our lives
and the other is your brain is a time
machine the neuroscience and physics of
time
i have to admit in fact that i've often
gotten this wrong you know when i go
around giving talks
about time i i said something that i now
realize or i
recently figured out isn't quite right
about how the brain
tells time you know we have artificial
time
keeping and time measuring devices
clocks and so forth calendars
and basically these work by looking at
oscillations it's something that happens
over and over again
and we accumulate a certain number of
oscillations to see how much time has
passed
as dean will explain that is basically
not how the brain works the brain uses
other mechanisms it's more like an
hourglass
than a ticking watch or something like
that but more importantly it's not just
that the brain measures time
the brain uses time to model the world
right because our world is four
dimensional there's three dimensions of
space one dimension of time
so what the brain does is to construct a
model of reality
because we human beings need to live in
reality we need to predict what's going
to happen next
we have a feeling that certain results
will occur
if we make certain actions and so forth
obviously
time plays a huge role here and i think
that's what is
dean's deeper interest here because he's
interested in the laws of physics as
well as in
neuroscience he's trying to understand
how the brain constructs a model of
reality and what
relationship that has to actual reality
right
are we just constructing an illusion are
we finding
touching something real about the world
and
in fact we end up having more of a
conversation between dean and myself
in this podcast episode than i usually
have here on mindscape
because we're interested in the same
things but coming at them from two
different perspectives so we don't agree
about everything but we agree about a
lot and i think that we really got into
some deep
fun questions about what is reality what
is time
how do we measure it how do we think
about it so i think this is a really
great
episode that i'm very happy with let's
[Music]
go
dean bonamano welcome to the mindscape
podcast it's a pleasure to be here sean
thank you
every time that i deal with someone who
is a neuroscientist or thinking about
consciousness and things like that
i can't help but think wow this is
really really complicated i'm glad i
don't do it
for a living are you the kind of
neuroscientist help our audience figure
this out who sort of studies
neuron by neuron or function by function
or thinks big picture about like
consciousness and what that is
yeah it's interesting that you put it
that way and it's
neuroscientists feel the same way about
theoretical physics of course um it's
glad
that i don't do that i'm certainly
consider myself to be a neuroscientist
who tries to understand the big picture
question so there's it's a huge field as
you know
and some uh neuroscientists study
molecular biologies and spend
a long part of their life trying to
focus on
a particular molecule or protein that
might be involved with the disease
i really focus on how the brain performs
computations
how the brain makes processes time
engages in decision making and so forth
learns and so forth but you started off
with a question of it's
it's very complicated and indeed it's so
complicated that i don't know if we have
any right to think that we can
understand it because the brain
is the most neuroscience is the most
recursive field of all scientific fields
right because
neuroscience is the only field in which
the thing being studied is doing the
study
so so i don't know if we'll figure it
out or not but it's certainly fun trying
and there's a lot of job security
because i don't think we'll actually
make much progress
um within my lifetime towards the deeper
questions i suppose cosmologists could
say that it's the universe trying to
figure out the universe
but it's a little bit less direct than
in your case you know
there's that um there's that anecdote of
a neuroscientist and
physicist talking and the physicist says
um
the most important problem is science is
what's the origin of the universe
and the neuroscientist says what organ
led you to that decision
um so yeah they're they're they're
they're interactive right and this is a
fun aspect i think of
that's fun to talk to you i mean there
are links here between the neuroscience
and the physics
well and also between the world of
computation you
you use the word computation as
something that the brain does and
i'd always i always hesitate a little
bit about that word because clearly the
brain does computations but
it lets us or it invites us
to use actual physical computers as a
metaphor for the brain
and in many ways the brain is not
designed the same way
as my laptop is uh is that something you
think about a lot
absolutely the and again we we probably
just want to define
what we mean by the word computation so
of course the brain
doesn't perform computations in a serial
manner like a von neumann architecture
like our serial computers do
but it certainly is a computational
device in the sense that it processes
information
as inputs it generates outputs
now in terms of the comparison between
digital computers and biological
computers or the brain at least
they're they're adapted they're
optimized for different computations so
i i i you know i went into neuroscience
because
neuroscience was it was fascinating that
the brain
could bestow us with consciousness and
the ability to
communicate and to pat our tummies and
rub our heads at the same time and
other cool things like that but as i
grow grumpier you know
the brain also sucks in many ways right
the brain
you know if if you ask me what's
62 times 79 i'm like
uh let me go get a calculator which is a
bit embarrassing right
because the brain is the most
sophisticated computational device we
know of
and by almost any
measure of computational complexity
multiplication is much easier than
recognizing faces so why is it so bad at
some things versus
versus others so any piece of hardware
is well suited for some temptations and
poorly suited for others
i do wonder whether or not we would be
able to artificially enhance ourselves
along those lines like i think
i'm embarrassingly i'm going to forget
who it was um
that i was talking to about this but i
conjectured that
uh there was sort of an uncertainty
principle that made it difficult to be a
conscious creature and
do math perfectly at the same time right
like not only were we not optimized for
it but
there's a reason why we're bad at it but
on the other hand if we just
get a neural lace or an implant that we
can plug into
a phone or a calculator could we imagine
enhancing our abilities along those
lines pretty
straightforwardly yeah i think that's uh
increasingly
topical and relevant question first in
regards to
the trade-off what you're getting to is
a trade-off between say being conscious
and doing mathematical computation so i
agree with that
and if you look at neurons
as computational hardware computational
building blocks
they're not well suited for math
so no engineer or computer scientist
would use neurons to build a calculator
because
math benefits from digital precision
digital switch-like properties so
transistors are great switches
neurons are horrible switches they're
great coincidence detectors
so people say well why are we so bad at
math and people say well because we
didn't evolve to do that i would
actually disagree with that i think
of course that's one reason but i think
additionally
that the biological hardware evolution
had as its disposal
is not well suited for numerical
calculations mental numerical
calculations so i think it's a hardware
problem
now in our ability to interface
with brain machine interfaces neural
hybrid computing
and so forth absolutely i think
we'll take step in those directions it's
interesting right and i think there's a
bit of
fanfare or a bit of exaggeration in this
field
you know we say well we can interface
computational devices with the brain
maybe directly
in a neural links type fashion
directly implanting them into the brain
but you know the fact of the matter is
sean we already have pretty good
interfaces right eyes and ears
and you know they're not bad interfaces
and we use them quite
quite well so this idea that we're going
to dramatically expand
our cognitive abilities with these
interfaces i'm a bit skeptical and let
me just give you one example there
thought so so knowledge is the
infrastructure of thought
right so in order to think about the
problem you have to have that
the data already built in embedded into
your neural circuits
if i ask you to think about a problem in
physics
to create some novel idea you need to
have those
primitive concepts already embedded in
your circuits that's why you think about
something differently than i think about
something
so the idea that somebody who doesn't
know anything about quantum physics
will just tap into their mental
interface
and load that up into their brain they
might gather information but i don't
think they'll be able to
build upon that information because
because that information
is the substrate of creativity and
thought
could you i want to follow up on that
but first i just got to go back to this
neurons not being good
uh calculators a little bit can you
expand on that a little bit because
i think that again people do have this
metaphor in mind about the laptop and
and the brain
and the fact that the hardware is
ill-suited to the task is actually
not something i'd heard before i'd heard
the evolution explanation for why we're
not good at multiplication
so the hardware of the brain
is based on neurons so neurons are these
amazing computational devices
and they're very they're very
extroverted compared to transistors
right a transistor is a computational
device that switches
from two states a binary state and it
receives input from
not that many other of its neighbors
neurons are connected to thousands and
thousands of its neighbors and they're
very democratic
they um sum up their excitatory and
inhibitory
inputs and then produce an output but
once they produce an
output they immediately forget it they
don't they're not a switch-like property
so
as you know if you're doing addition of
binary numbers
switch like properties are very
important because once you switch
you're adding two numbers if you sort of
want to carry
the remainder right you need to fix the
current result
remember what happened and then bring in
the other numbers
neurons are horrible at that because
they're leaky
they don't they're not switches is i
think the clearest way to put it is
transistors the the foundation of
current
computers are transistors which have
switch-like properties
neurons are integrated i'm certain
i shouldn't say integrators i should say
they're coincidence detectors
they sort of um sum up the votes and
either produce an output or not but once
that output is generated
it's gone okay and but nevertheless we
can
add two digit numbers together right so
there's some collective property that is
mimicking some virtual machine that is
running in our head that is sort of a
pretty shaky but still functional
calculator
yeah um speaking
for myself you know it's incredibly
shaky right
and me too don't worry you know you know
if
there's no way no human being
will ever divide ten
divide two ten digit numbers with this
in mentally without using pen and paper
with the same precision and accuracy
as any even the simple calculator on
on your watch so yes but remember
unlike face recognition which is
something that's a relatively
hard computation that's something that
most computers have only um excelled at
recently
human babies do that they don't need to
go to school to learn to recognize faces
you need to learn to you need to go to
school to learn to do the math so you're
clearly tapping in to symbolic reasoning
representations that are not in the
brain's normal uh
wheelhouse i guess this is a completely
uh different topic than i thought we'd
eventually be talking about but it will
eventually lead into
questions about how we represent the
world and do physics and things like
that so it's relevant but
do we know much about how the brain
has decided to do arithmetic or simple
math things
no i i i don't think so the best we've
known about is counting
so even counting is tricky right so
representing numbers symbolically
um can animals count animals can do
something called subitization
which is judging looking at a
image and seeing which image has more um
elements objects
seeds food whatever so that's a simple
comparison task
yeah it's sort of a subitization means
um sort of
guesstimating the numbers or the
quantity or the magnitude of elements
in a in an image for example so
they can train uh monkeys to make
a comparison task as you just said
between
um does this image have more or less of
those items and then they
can record from neurons in the brain and
they see that some neurons are tuned for
magnitude
but that's probably not how humans are
doing
math we're probably just tapping into
language symbolic reasoning and these
higher order
cognitive abilities that are really more
closely associated with human cognition
it's just one of the reasons why
physicists will always be jealous of
neuroscientists because it's just so
easy to ask a question that we don't
know the answer to
in neuroscience there's like so many
things yet to be done which
which is great um and and as i said yeah
it's the brain
trying to figure out itself so it's it's
an
uphill battle and you mentioned the fact
that an individual neuron
takes in a lot of data and you know
talks to a lot of
its friends and also there's this
well-known fact that the way
that we make memories or something like
that is not
i mean i say it's a well-known fact
you're probably gonna tell me i'm wrong
here but
it's not that we change the internal
chemistry of the neuron but we change
how the neurons are linked together in
the strength
of those linkages is that right that's
exactly right at least the main
mechanism seems to be what we call
synaptic plasticity
so if if we're two neurons and we're
connected
learning or one of the main mechanisms
of learning
seems to be changing the weight of those
synapses the coefficients between those
two
elements and here there's very
interesting physical analogies
and of course this is the same way a lot
of the
current deep learning machine learning
approaches in a.i function of course is
by just
adjusting the weights what
neuroscientists
call the weights or the synaptic
strength between two neurons and
in machine learning or in other fields
you can just think of as the
coefficients between two elements
okay yeah and is that that was
explicitly inspired by
the human brain or by brains right yeah
i think
a lot of the current d that's that's
right a lot of the deep learning
approaches were inspired by the brain's
architecture this fundamental
differences of course
um and i think we're reaching a
fascinating
convergence between neuroscience and
machine learning
where the question is is can machine
learning now inform neuroscience
as opposed to just the other way around
one of the things about
exercise is that it can be hard
sometimes to get motivated to do it
but once you get going it feels great
and that's what's so wonderful about the
peloton home
bike system it's there it's convenient
it's ready when you are
and then once you're on it you know that
you're doing something good for your
brain as well as for your body
and one of the things that keeps you
coming back to peloton is there's such a
variety of classes
and instructors and music you know some
of the instructors are there to make you
laugh
some will give you a little bit of extra
encouragement others are going to be
business-like and get down to work
whatever you're
in the mood for and peloton is flexible
in a lot of ways you can get one
subscription that will cover the whole
family for no additional cost you'll get
access to the entire class library
and the convenience of working out in
your home and the classes include
cardio of course but also strength
classes and you can combine
cardio and strength in one workout with
bike boot camp to get the total body
fitness experience
so get started on your peloton journey
go to one peloton.com to learn more
that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
well that's part maybe that's related to
what i was going to ask next which is
that not only i think that what people
hear what i have heard uh for a long
time is that the strength of neural
connections
helps us form memories or something like
that but what about this
question of algorithms you know there's
some self-organization
process that has to go on uh is it the
same thing is it the strength of the
connections and do we know much about
how the brain
grows its algorithms yeah so that's a
great question
so first the difference between
algorithms and memory in a way
arises from is influenced or is biased
by
our understanding of computers with von
neumann architecture right that's sort
of a
key aspect of of our digital computers
is that they have memory
and they have these algorithms
that are processing the information
stored in those memories so in the brain
it's probably not a good idea to
necessarily necessarily
separate the algorithms from the memory
okay so this was
what i was just hinting at is if we have
these brain machine interfaces
maybe a way this is a better way to put
it is we have these brain machine
interfaces
the memory is the substrate for the
computation is the substrate for the
algorithm so
those things aren't as clearly distinct
in the brain so so it's absolutely valid
to say
that how you process information
um is in part dependent on changes in
synaptic
strength and um as well as the memory
is also dependent on the change of
synaptic strength now what governs
the ch what governs how synaptic
strengths change
so maybe that's what you refer to
algorithms and that's what we refer to
the learning rules
so the simplest learning rule we know of
is called
hebbian plasticity or hebbian learning
which just states that
the strength between two neurons
increases if they're
correlated with each other so if neuron
a is active at the same time as neuron b
then the strength between those uh two
neurons increases
so that's an algorithm and that's sort
of programmed genetically
into the system and that's the
self-organizing
learning rules that govern the emergence
of these complex properties so any
emergent system
has underlying learning rules simple
relatively simple learning rules that
generate surprisingly complex properties
good and one of the uses to which we put
that capability
is mapping or making a model of the
world in which we live
right um i'm especially impressed by
what we've learned over recent years i
know your expertise is in time but let's
just talk about space
a little bit i mean where we are in the
world has
really interesting reflections in our
neural architecture
so yes we have these very sophisticated
spatial maps that allow us to
interact with the world right there's
nothing um more
basic for animals is to be able to
navigate their world right this is one
of the differences between plants
and animals right so animal plants don't
need to navigate their world they just
stay fixed
but animals need to navigate the world
and that cr that requires these
sophisticated
spatial maps if you close your eyes and
most animals can navigate in the dark if
you close your eyes
you can navigate in your surroundings
because you have an internal map that
allows you to do some dead reckoning and
to
give directions on where you want to go
and this is
this is something all animals are good
at and and
something here that i think is worth
saying is
that the same is not true for time
okay so most animals do not navigate
time or how could they
right um so but most animals
they seem to have a map so migrating
birds can
navigate over very long distances time
is very different
so you know you and i can say well
next month i'm going on a trip that i
planned last year
so we have these complex temporal
relationships that we can
transmit but most animals seem to live
in the present so they don't have these
temporal maps to the same degree
that we do i did
uh have carl fristen on the podcast and
i joked with him that i thought that it
was
uh cats domestic house cats that was the
level of um
evolutionary progress at which the
ability to think about the future must
have developed because i have two cats
and one of them clearly does it and the
other one clearly
does not so i don't know if it's
scientifically proven but it seems to be
evident so give me an example of your
cat i'm thinking about the future
well yeah so one cat caliban he just
lives in the moment he does
he's either happy or unhappy depending
on whether the present moment is suiting
his purposes but ariel his sister
she knows that if she does certain
things other things will follow
and you know she will plan them out so
she plays fetch you know she'll bring
you a little ball and you're supposed to
throw it
and come back and she knows that if she
walks to the bathroom
will turn on the shower and she'll be
able to take a shower and things like
that and so
her happiness or lack of happiness is
clearly dependent on
what she anticipates is going to happen
in the future in a way that her brothers
is not
and how far into the future do you think
her actions
are are can go so are we talking minutes
seconds or i think minutes maybe i would
say minutes but maybe it's only seconds
so so this is an interesting question
and this speaks to
the problem of mental time travel which
for humans you know mental time travel
is refers to our ability to
mentally i know we have differing
differing views of um whether time
travel
is possible in physics but but i think
we can probably agree that
um the closest we'll ever come to temp
time travel is mental time travel we can
sort of revisit
we can revisit the past in our minds and
we can
simulate possible future scenarios we
can practice
um for and and prepare for
these these podcasts for example now
in that that ability in many ways is
what makes homo sapiens sapien
right it's what makes homo sapiens wise
you think of something
like agriculture which was in the most
transformative
technological invention inventions of
our species
that requires planting a seed today and
reaping the fruits of that seed
maybe a year into the future that
connecting
cause and effect between over a year far
as far
beyond the cognitive capacity of all
other animals as far
as we know so all animals the brain
is a device that helps animals predict
the future and that includes um
taliban yeah so so
all animals can anticipate what's about
to happen in
on the seconds frame and and probably
more
on the minutes frame because if they
couldn't they wouldn't survive in a
world governed by
the laws of physics they need to know
where the prey is they need to know
where the water is they need to know
um how to avoid being
predated but to to think about things in
a flexible manner like saving for
retirement
or brushing your teeth um you know
everything we do is future oriented it's
hard to find something that we do that's
not future oriented and
you know you know i think my dog like
brushing my teeth
you know i can't convince him to brush
his teeth it's hard to explain
that this is something that you should
do for your future well-being
and and it's not something that most
animals
can um grasp there's there's
is discussion there have been
experiments on mental time travel in
some birds and so there's a debate
that some animals can engage in mental
time travel um but it's still
an open debate i love my cats but
neither one of them is going to be
uh retiring uh planning for their
retirement very effectively
so you can't count so you can't count on
them to support you in your old days i
would love to i would love to but
but okay i mean this the the juicy time
stuff is is creeping in on us because we
both want to talk about it but i want to
finish with space
first um there are literally neurons in
our brain
that help us you said as we as you said
we close our eyes
and we can still sort of have a picture
of what's going on in the world
i was just really surprised to learn
that there's different neurons that have
different jobs telling us where we are
telling us how we're oriented uh placing
grids on the world around us and and
telling us where we are relative to
different nodes in that grid this is
just amazing to me
indeed and this was a topic that led to
the nobel prize
i think a couple of years ago of place
cells and grid cells and people have
discovered
place cells in the hippocampus and if
you record from place cells in the
brains of rats
um as they're traveling a room
those specific neurons might start
firing
in a specific location in that room um
or um specific
amount of distance when it's running on
a treadmill so
and then there's these other more sort
of higher order
complexity of spatial cells these are
grid cells that you're referring to that
that fire in these beautiful periodic
patterns they'll fire at one meter in
and then two meters in and then three
meters in and so you have these grids
as desolation if you will right i'm
sorry and not in between it's as if
you know there's a giant chess board and
without actually the chess board
being colored at all there are neurons
that fire if you're on a black square
but not a white square
and exactly i don't know why that's true
is there some evolutionary explanation
for that
i don't think there's a generally agreed
upon uh
explanation for that sean i think
mathematically
you you've seen these patterns in
different aspects of mathematically
grids
and can be useful for encoding
information in
in numerous um um circumstances and one
thing nice about grids
is invariance right so with changing one
variable or two variables of a grid
you can change expand or dilate that
grid or expand or contract that grid
and then remap the system to a larger
room or a smaller room
so but but that's all sort of
speculation
or or theories so i don't think we have
a at least that i know of i don't think
we have a universally agreed upon answer
to that question
how much of our very what a philosopher
called the manifest image of the world
our very basic idea that there is
three-dimensional space around us full
of objects these objects take up space
etc
how much of that is in some sense innate
is any of it or do you have to learn
all of it i mean the human brain is not
completely a blank slate but is there
little tiny folk physics built into it
i think so so clearly it's the case
that there's areas specialized in
processing spatial information so
humans that have lesions
to certain parts of the brain will have
typical deficits in spatial navigation
or getting lost
and and so forth so the brain is
absolutely not a blank
slate in this sort of deeper level
now how that's applied everybody
will um develop specific
skills to navigate their local
environment whether you grew up in a
forest or a city
and and so forth but you know something
interesting about space
you're talking about the space of around
us you know there's another very
interesting aspect of this
which is your body you know you feel
if if i were to um
stab your hand you feel pain
projected out into 3d space at the point
in space in which that piece of meat
that is your hand
happens to be so in many ways
i think spatial awareness the driving
force from spatial awareness was body
awareness
yeah and that the body is the brain's
most important possession
yeah so it needs to have this
beautiful very compelling map it's it's
really
it's really amazing right i mean why do
i feel my hand
as my hand right and it's an amazingly
amazingly powerful illusion
and it's let's face it it's just a piece
of meat attached to my brain through
some nerves
but i have a very intimate awareness of
where it is
of of of that it belongs to me and so
forth so it's an amazing spatial
illusion this sounds kind of like a very
specific hypothesis that one might even
ask about testing the idea that we
developed spatial recognition
capabilities generally out of first
developing
a question of where we our where we are
our bodies are located
in space is that something that people
try to figure out if that was the right
way that it happened
i don't know if evolutionarily speaking
i i think the way i guess i should
probably put it is those two things
probably had to co-evolve right
because they're intimately tied together
so almost all
animals have a map of their own body in
their brains
so as you know we have a somatosensory
map the homunculus
that maps out my body and it's a very
sophisticated map and by the way it's
not one map it's many maps
there's many homunculi in our brains
that map out different aspects of our
body
now in order that to be functional it's
also important to
if i'm going to interact with the
external world i'm going to
try to eat a fly
or pick up an object that my body map
has to also be mapped onto this external
map
so now that you're sort of
bringing those up in context i would say
that i think they have to really
be tightly inextricably linked and have
co-evolved with each other
it makes sense i mean i know that people
who study virtual reality suggest
that you can remap your homunculus a
little bit right you can
sort of train it to believe it has more
arms or legs than it has
i've always wondered not always that's
an exaggeration but for a long time i've
wondered
could you have four dimensional space
in virtual reality could you train the
brain to think that it was
in a higher dimensional space
i don't know but um i'm suspicious
of of you asking that question as an
eternalist sean
um so so i hope not no i'm kidding
um i think i
i doubt it i sincerely doubt it you know
i think that's something that is so
fundamental to evolution
that it would be hard and hard to really
compellingly achieve that awareness
four-dimensional
awareness you know some professions and
you're probably in one of those
professions
and many other um mathematically
um rich professions have a lot of um
[Music]
benefit in being able to visualize or
imagine high dimensional systems right
no nor science is that way by the way
and you know we all have our little
hacks but
you know i don't think most people can
claim to have
a good intuition of four-dimensional uh
navigation
so i i think that would be
a stretch to to have that ability but
i could be wrong good phd project for
one of your students i'm just saying
the student you least want to talk to
send them down this terrible rabbit hole
of impossible
questions okay good so that's i i did
want to get space on the board there as
it were but time is is
is what we're really here to chat about
so we have a map
of space we have cells that tell us
where we are
is time keeping completely different
from that in the brain
or is there like a time cell in the
brain
i think the answer is both so
first it's useful to have a bit of an
analogy here with
physical devices so because it pertains
to scale so
the answer to your question depends on
time scale so
here to give some context you know
man-made devices if you need to
weigh out a gram of salt or your weight
in the morning
or your car you have a different
physical device
to measure mass across scales
man-made clocks are quite incredible
right because the same man-made clock
it's really astounding can measure
microseconds milliseconds seconds
minutes hours days and so forth it's
it's quite an achievement
the brain can also measure
times across a vast range of scales so
what i'm getting to of course is your
question is dependent on scale
so we can measure microseconds on
the time it takes sound to travel from
my right ear to my left ear
and days for our circadian clock of
course
the brain has absolutely fundamentally
different mechanisms for timing on those
scales
so it's what we might think of as a
multiple clock principle
so the circadian clock certainly doesn't
have a
second hand yeah um it just has an
hour hand and tells days but has no idea
how many days have gone by
so it's very specialized for that
24-hour cycle
the timing that underlies your ability
to detect sound coming from your right
ear to
on the right side of your head to the
left side is
can pick up tens of microseconds but it
has no idea how many minutes have gone
by so the brain
in part because presumably because of
the evolutionary constraints
of biological systems it had to
develop or evolve different
timing mechanisms to solve the problems
on different scales
and circadian clock functions as
one as an oscillator as a molecular
oscillator it has
what's called a transcription
translation
autoregulatory feedback loop okay and
that just means that it makes
dna and the dna makes rna and the rna
makes proteins
and those proteins in turn inhibit the
synthesis of more dna
so you have this recursive system that
um cycles upon itself
now on this one once every 24 hours
yes approximately once every 24 hours so
that is the thing that is most
analogous to the mechanical clocks that
we build where it's really an oscillator
with some
period that is more or less reliable
so exactly and that's a good uh
point to bring up too so you know
man-made clocks are can be
very incredibly into their degree of
sophistication
but they really rely on an almost
embarrassingly simple concept right just
counting the ticks of a time base of an
oscillator that time base might be a
pendulum swing or a
vibration of quartz crystal or the
cesium atom electromagnetic frequency
but they're all just counting the ticks
of those oscillators
and but but sean it's important to note
that the second part of that requires
integration
or accounting yeah the so it's sort of
timing above the period right of the
time base
the circadian clock is timing below the
period
of the time base so it's the phase okay
of course
so it's telling the phase of the
oscillation
so um now so sorry to say in other words
the circadian clock doesn't tell you how
many days have passed it tells you what
time of day it is where you are within
that cycle a hundred percent so your
circadian clock
located your main circadian clock
located in your hypothalamus has no idea
how old you are right
um it just says time to get up time to
go to bed
now this notion of having an oscillator
and a counter
was really one of the main theories of
how the brain tells time
for for really most of the 20th century
it's called the internal clock theory
and it's a reasonable theory in the
sense that brains i mean sorry neurons
can be reasonably good oscillators
neurons are good oscillators
they can go up and down at a fairly
constant rate and that's a good thing
right because that underlies breathing
that underlies chewing that underlies
walking
but as we've already discussed neurons
are horrible counters
they're horrible integrators so it's
pretty clear today that this internal
clock theory is not really
the correct one in terms of the main way
the brain
tells time rather any
dynamical system any system that changes
in some reproducible fashion
can be used to tell time in principle
and the brain of course is the most
complex dynamical system we know of
so it makes sense that the brain uses
its own dynamics
as a way to tell time and that seems to
be that's something that
my lab has worked on um on a lot
and it's becoming increasingly clear
that
in many cases your brain is telling time
by changing patterns of neural activity
i think you're gonna have to give me
more details about what that means
so one way to tell time you can imagine
uh you have a circuit of neurons
so you have neuron a neuron b and the
most trivial
sort of population clock or neural clock
you can think of
is just a chain of neural activity
neuron a activates b
activates c activate d it's a very
simple almost trivial concept
and you can imagine that depending on
the time delay between that activation
sort of like
dominoes falling down you can time the
dominoes and you know that when domino
100 fell down
a hundred milliseconds have passed
whatever so
neural neurons are dynamical systems uh
a excites b
b excites c c inhibits a so you have all
this complex
high dimensional dynamics which can be
used
to tell time i mean you know you imagine
in physics um you have a ball
rolling down a landscape and you could
use that as a clock if you so desired
right as long as it was relatively
reproducible with a certain degree of
precision so
so i think on the scale of seconds
the intrinsic dynamics of neural
circuits seems to be
one of the key ways the brain is telling
time is it fair to say
reaching for an analogy the brain on the
scale of seconds tells time
with mechanisms that are more like an
hourglass than a wristwatch
because there's something that is
changing uniformly and you see where you
are in that process
yes i think that's fair to say because
the wristwatch is clearly what you're
getting to is the wristwatch is clearly
relying on an oscillation and counting
the ticks of those isolations
whereas a uh hourglass
is just a physical system
that's governed by um
the laws of gravity in this case and it
has a specific reproducible dynamics
that can be used to tell time and
something that i remember from your book
is that you can train these mechanisms
right you can get better at them and
you can get better at one of them on one
time scale without any change in your
ability to take
to tell time on other time scales that's
yes absolutely correct it's not even on
other time scales it's even within the
time scale so if i
trained you if i gave you some software
and trained you on discriminating a
short interval very short like 100 or
200 milliseconds
you would get better at that over the
course of days but your ability to tell
time across
500 milliseconds would not improve
so the mechanism so this goes again to
the idea of why it's different from
a a quartz uh
wristwatch right if you get if your
watch is
tuned well for uh it gets better at 100
milliseconds it's going to get better as
the other intervals as well
so the idea here is that the brain tells
time through not through a centralized
clock but through many
different circuits that are specialized
for different functions
i think that the whole lesson of this
podcast is the brain is bad at counting
it could very well be sean yes i mean
it's it would seem like
you know the thing that happens in a
wristwatch where you have
a second hand an hour and a minute hand
uh like you say it's the same oscillator
that drives them all but there's some
differential gears right relating
the actual motion of the hands that
doesn't seem to be a mechanism that
evolution ever
thought up right it
it's certainly something that the brain
is not inherently well suited at doing
have you
as you've said we can do it we can get
by and animals can
too but it requires rather than
requiring one neuron or two neurons it
requires a whole circuit of neurons
generally to
hack it yeah to do the counting and you
know and this is clear from our behavior
right i mean
you know babies have to learn to count
you have to teach them there's there's
whole
native native indians in the amazon
have a one two and many system of
counting yeah
they don't really know their age they
don't really
count past the number of ten which is
very surprising to us
but counting is something that we in in
western educated um in our western
educated world take for granted but
it's not as universal as we think it is
so if you can train yourself are there
certain professions that are very
naturally good
at keeping time i was going to guess
musicians and then i thought of
what about comedians timing is
everything right like are there
are there things that you do that
naturally hone your skills at
time keeping in different time scales
how how about
podcasters has has your timing terrible
and terrible
as you know we have to delay this for a
week because i'm not very good at
organizing my time
yeah i guess podcasters have more
flexibility
in the duration you can edit of of the
of the interview and they can edit but
in a lot of professions so like in
in radio hosts where they have a five
minute slot
they can get quite good at sort of
having an intuitive
feel of what that five minutes but of
course so you're absolutely correct
musicians when have have very good
timing
on on the scale of of
hundreds of milliseconds and so forth um
but timing we're all pretty good at him
and and here's an example so you said
you mentioned comedians right and of
course com
timing is as as as we often say is
is critical in comedy but it's really
critical in speech
yeah and here's an example i'll say two
phrases
and depending on the timing of my speech
the meaning is different
they gave her cat food or they gave her
cat
food so there's two very different
meanings
there and so you're continuously telling
time
everything you do is occurring in time
and another example of that
is right now your brain is unconsciously
attempting to predict what i'm about to
say so by pausing my speech
that created what's called the temporal
prediction error
in your brain and you said uh is dean
forgot his word am i supposed to say
something and so forth so your brain is
unconsciously
continuously telling time and attempting
to predict what's about to happen
this is actually of crucial importance
for podcasting because a lot of people
listen to podcasts
sped up i don't know if you know this
right and the best way but you want to
speed it up but not obviously increase
the pitch of everything
so you clip and you get rid of all the
silences and things like that and people
have started to complain that if you
listen to the podcast sped up
all of the nuance of the timing in the
speech gets uh
evaporated away yeah it's interesting
and
and i wonder if you're training people's
brains to process speech at faster rates
and and so forth so yeah again it is an
interesting
somebody should be studying that i agree
uh and other things just
besides just training they're sure there
are other things that affect the
accuracy at which we can tell time right
i mean
i we briefly talked when david eagleman
was on the podcast about being scared
having your adrenaline going and how
that affects your time keeping but
presumably
the brain is awash in signals and
chemicals and
influences and these have a an influence
on how well we're keeping track of time
and psychoactive drugs and everybody
reports
that this influences our
perception of time and this is a deep
mystery but in many ways
i think the question might be
misdirected
so clearly we all know that the
subjective flow of the passage of time
can be dependent on context whether
you're bored or excited
or having fun or engaged hopefully for
the listeners of this podcast they're
saying wow time really flew by
riveted um so
and then of course in near-death
situations time
often is reported to have slowed down
so you can imagine a couple of things
underlying that so one you can imagine
that the brain is being overclocked so
just like you can
increase the speed of your computer you
can overclock it everything happens
faster so things
transpire at a faster rate the brain
there's no reason to
believe the brain can be overclocked
neurons don't work like that yeah
maybe you can accelerate things by ten
percent but there's no clock to be
overclocked
and there's physical time constants that
you know are constrained by the physics
of neurons and so forth so it's very
hard to imagine that you're going to get
if you're full of adrenaline that you're
going to get neurons processing
20 30 40 maybe 20 30 40 faster but not
100 200 faster you might also imagine
that it's an illusion in the sense that
time doesn't change
it's just your memory of what happened
changes
so it's sort of like a flash bulb effect
that it's not when i was in a car
accident
time seemed to slow down it's that when
i have very good recall of what happened
and that produces that
slowing down i actually recount the
story of when i was in a car accident
and my car was spinning around that i've
caught myself thinking wow time really
does slow down when you're about to die
um so i don't think it's it's memory
either uh so i think the correct
question
is what is our normal sense of time and
and
if you give me some leeway let me go
back to an example
with a body awareness so as you know
there's a
syndrome called
phantom limbs so people can feel people
who have
suffered an amputation can still feel
that limb
as vividly as you and i feel our own
limbs which found
sounds very bizarre but the real lesson
in phantom limbs
is not that the brain somehow um
miscalculates and generates an illusion
of the phantom limb
the real illusion is our normal limbs as
we just discussed it's just that the
brain continues or insists on
on continuing with the illusion of body
even though
that part of the body is no longer there
so the correct question is
not what causes phantom limbs but what
causes normal body awareness and i think
this is the same in the context of time
so the question is not why
time is distorted but what is our
true normal what we call our normal
sense of the passage of time and we know
that in some sense
this is an illusion and this maybe we
can step slightly into the physics soon
so and what i say by illusion is we
perceive time to be flowing
as a continuous linear
narrative of what's happening in the
external world that's what it feels like
but we know that's not the case at the
conscious level so of course
unconsciously your brain is continuously
processing
um information that's coming in but
things only get
created or sent to consciousness in sort
of fits
and bursts so your brain your
unconscious brain
delivers into consciousness
[Music]
interpretations of what's happening in
this external world
in sort of a highly edited cut and
pasted way much like you'll probably do
to this podcast
so and here's an example of that so
again i'm going to say two sentences
she had a stake in the company she had a
steak on the grill
okay so hopefully
you understood the homophone
steak there to have two very different
meanings but you could only under know
the meaning by the words that came after
yeah so i think for most people
they don't necessarily go they don't
necessarily interpret consciously what
steak means and then
re-edit their interpretation of steak
they wait the unconscious brain waits
for the finish
the end of the sentence to provide a
conscious
conscious interpretation of what steak
made i don't know what your
interpretation there i immediately
interpret it as food but that might be
because it's lunchtime and i'm hungry so
that's
fair enough um it does it is a bit of a
rorschach test there i guess
um in terms of what you're thinking so
so but in in many cases if we if we
change this to say
you know if i say chickpea or chicken
right
it's not like you understood chick and
then modified what chick means by what
came after so
clearly much of our interpretation of
what's happening in the external world
is processed unconsciously and then wait
and then the unconscious brain waits
until
certain key um points
in that narrative to generate conscious
experience so in that sense it's
illusion but at the deeper sense
the question is is our subjective
feeling of the flow of time and the
subjective
feeling that the past is no longer real
and that the future
is not yet real is that an illusion or
not
and the degree to which that um
creates tension with physics yeah um and
i think
you have one perspective maybe you could
tell me about what you
if you view the degree to which you view
our conscious perception of the past no
longer being real
and the future not yet being real as a
creation of the human mind or an
illusion
yeah so i almost never use the word
illusion in these contexts
because i think that there i would much
rather talk about you know higher level
emergent approximate descriptions of
reality that are not necessarily
capturing the fundamental stuff but are
still capturing something
real um but having said that yeah i
think that our
uh so let me talk for just a couple
minutes which i try not to do on the
podcast but
this is something i do think about um
you know i i think as a physicist that
it makes most sense
to be an eternalist in some sense about
time to attribute equal amounts of
reality to the past present and future
and then of course the big question
which i completely
agree is a big question is how is it
that we perceive it
so differently that we that we seem to
perceive the present moment as real
and attribute such very different
ontological status to the past and
future
and to no one's surprise who has
listened to me talk before or read my
books etc
it's because of the arrow of time and
increasing entropy
and uh i think that you know aside from
a few rhetorical flourishes you and i
are not so far
apart uh in this um maybe putting
emphasis here or there
i had janae and ismael on the podcast i
don't know if you know janan's work
she's a
philosopher but she keeps up a lot with
um both the physics and the neuroscience
sides of things and she gives this very
what is to me a compelling story of
where our impression of flowing through
time or traveling through time comes
from
in terms of exactly what you've already
described namely that
our brains are constantly both
remembering where we just came from and
comparing it to where we think we are
and predicting where we think we're
going to be and sort of updating that
prediction in real time so
it's exactly because the arrow of time
gives us
slightly unbalanced access to the
immediate past and future and our
abilities to predict or retroject those
that we have this feeling of flowing of
being pulled or pushed or whatever you
want to call it
uh through time even though at the level
of fundamental physics
all the moments are equally real that's
the spiel i would give
and you're certainly wise in
being cautious about the word illusion
because particularly
in for physicists and and
neuroscientists we use that word
in very different ways but
but in many ways most of our subjective
perceptions
are mental constructs the degree to
which those mental constructs
correlate with reality is i think what
we're ultimately having a conversation
about
so in neuroscience say color
color is a mental construct and color
doesn't really exist in physics what you
have
is um wavelength of electromagnetic
radiation
and our perception of color is sort of
evolution's hack
to create a spectrometer so it's an
illusion
and and
but most of the time it's fairly well
correlated with physical reality
unless we're looking at um
gold and blue colored dresses on on
twitter
but for the most time most of the cases
the
evolutionary value the adaptive value of
perceiving color is that it detects
something that's a mental con it's
creates something that's a mental
construct but it's correlated with
physical reality
so we have to remember that subjective
experiences are evolutionarily adaptive
so now the question is
is let's not focus on the flow of
time let's focus on the subjective
feeling that the past is no longer real
and that the future is that's related
but i think it's an important distinct
distinction that will help our this
discussion
so we subjectively feel
very saliently incredibly silently the
past is no longer real our local past is
no longer real and the future is not yet
real and that's
that's fundamental to how the brain
works because one of the brain's jobs to
predict the future in order to allow for
survival so
as i understand it i think
that you would have to classify that
as and i'm going to use the word
illusion although i know you don't like
that
but something misleading about the
physical world
that that doesn't reflect physical
reality because the
past is in some sense as you just put it
um
equally as real as as the present
and the future and we have to be i know
we we have to be very careful with words
here because
language is inherently present terrible
yeah complicated
yeah um but we're stuck there you have
it
um so i struggled now okay so
you the way you posed it i think you
used the word interpretation
of the laws of physics
but i struggle to know if you mean
interpretation or if you really think
it's
the laws of physics are conclusively
telling us that the world is
or the universe is eternalist so the way
i see it the laws of physics
aren't aren't inherently
present historic journalists the laws of
physics are somewhat agnostic to that
and we're imposing an interpretation on
those laws
and that interpretation can be biased by
the architecture of the brain
so what i think is worth
considering is the degree to which our
interpretation of the laws of physics
in this case the nature of time
is influenced by how our brains conceive
of time
well i think that this is actually a
good direction to go in because
i actually want to go back to the
illusion discussion a little bit because
i think it's relevant here it's not just
a a footnote
um but but first let me parenthetically
say that
uh steve savit who is a philosopher of
science who writes a lot about time
wrote he emailed me an article because i
was talking about
presentism and eternalism in the usual
way and he said don't do that there's no
difference between presentism and
eternalism they're just different words
to actually
describe exactly the same ontology and
it was actually a very compelling uh
believable article but i i emailed him
back and i said i bet all of your
eternalist friends like this and none of
your presenters friends agree with
it and he said yeah how did you know
because basically he was saying the
presidentists are just you know
determinists in denial uh sorry
eternalist in denial
but um i i would i'm sorry i i would
disagree with that
too with what he said and i think you as
you know
the the the benchmark
distinction between presentism and
eternalism is
time travel closed time like
close closed um close time like
curves is that the right term yes that's
exactly right
um so for a presenter
that's off the table right off the bat
yeah um
how can you visit the singer that
doesn't exist right
right right so you and you've you've
made the same point
in one of your books so i think there is
a very
relevant distinction between presentism
and eternalism
um i mean relevant not not not that it's
going to change our practical lives
in in any direct way um but i think at a
deep
question it's absolutely fundamental to
know
about the nature of reality i mean to me
it's very important to know if
if the past is in some way as true as
the present is the importance of the
present somehow
um not is just subjectively relevant not
objectively relevant so yeah so sorry i
didn't mean to interrupt you but
actually there is a very important
difference
that's very good let me follow up with
one comment on that before getting much
what i want to say and the comment is
that i think the point you're making is
that the difference between being a
presentist and an internalist
might if nothing else uh be relevant for
counterfactual claims right modal claims
as philosophers would say them
presidentists are going to think that
certain scenarios are just impossible to
physically realize even if we haven't
done it yet whereas an eternalist might
imagine that maybe someday
we would so in that case if that's true
and i haven't thought it through that
was a new idea
you just threw at me but yeah then i
would certainly grant that it makes a
difference if you're a present historian
eternalist
um but let me go back to the illusion
thing because i'm i'm
i know you said uh you get why i don't
like to use the word
illusion but maybe it's useful no i
don't think
it is useful ever and i think that the
i mean it's an illusion is when
you think something exists but it
literally doesn't
it's literally not there someone made a
coin disappear but it really didn't
disappear just went into their pocket
that's an illusion you think that
there's a
an oasis in the in the desert and you go
there and it's not there
that's an illusion but color is not an
illusion i can build a machine
that detects color perfectly well color
is just a
useful emergent way of packaging
microscopic details about the spectrum
of
wavelengths of light when people say
color is an illusion i
just don't get that i think that uh
color is no more an illusion than tables
and chairs
are illusions they're not there in the
fundamental laws of physics
but they're there and i think the same
thing is true with the flow of time it's
an
absolutely useful way of thinking and
conceptualizing about the world
in our everyday macroscopic manifest
image
even though it's nowhere to be found in
the fundamental laws
fair enough i think the
perhaps the word mental construct would
be
more useful and i'm i don't want to
defend the use of the word illusion but
when we
we need a word to describe some
degree of decoration between our mental
state
and our um and the physical state
and i don't know what word you'd prefer
but that sometimes we can think of
hallucinations
in which you have no correlation with
external world because you're internally
generating mental states that are
totally non-existent
in the external world now when you say
about the color
illusion not the illusion of color but a
color illusion where you misperceive the
color
of an object there's a decoration that's
right
but that decoration is allowed because
color is a mental construct now
so so i i i certainly agree with you
regarding
the caveats about the communication but
we should be aware i mean different
fields use the words in different ways
now regarding how the architecture of
our brain
influences our interpretation of these
laws so and and i think i'd like to ask
you a question but first let me
say that as we
already discussed the brain is well
suited for certain types of computations
recognizing faces but it's quite
horrible
at mental numerical calculations so the
architecture of the brain
is certainly well designed for some
things and not
others in the context of science
one of the best debugging devices we
have
one of the best ways we have to overcome
the brain's limitations
is called mathematics
because once some genius
conjures up some set of equations
that capture some truth about the
physical world
any nitwit like myself can use those
equations
plug those equations into a computer and
predict something that's going to happen
in the world and that act is independent
of the human mind
those equations quote speak for
themselves in a manner
of speaking but the minute we try to
interpret those equations
then we have to acknowledge that they're
being filtered through our brains
flaws gifts and all so
the question i pose to you
is presentism versus eternalism
an interpretation of the laws of physics
or a aspect of the laws of physics and
i'll put you on the spot here
if a to give you a thought experiment if
some
alien contacted you tonight um and you
were convinced this alien was
an omniscient being compared to us their
their technology was far superior to
ours and they told you
um sean we actually actually live in a
presentist universe
only the local present is real
do you feel that the law's physics would
have to be re
written or just reinterpreted yeah no i
i should have said that earlier
um i think i did use the word
interpretation i'm pretty happy with
that
um i do think that
for similar counterfactual reasons that
we discussed
it is interesting and important
to decide what we think is real
but in principle i could imagine the
current laws of physics
this is exactly what you're trying to
get me to admit but i'm happy to admit
it
uh are 100 compatible with a presentist
ontology where you think that the world
is fundamentally three-dimensional
existing at the current time and
evolving through
time in some way um
the fact that there are laws of physics
uh
especially those laws are deterministic
and you know we don't know for sure
whether they are or not but the fact
that they
are is what suggests to me that it
there's there's not embedded in the laws
of physics
any special pointer indicating the
present moment
as picked out in any way so i would
really want to quiz the alien on what
they meant by saying that they were
presentists
but i would be open to having the
conversation without necessarily
overturning my current understanding of
the laws of physics
so you just said that the laws of
physics and that's of course
true whether it's newtonian physics
quantum mechanics or relativity
don't have any special pointer that
point to the present
but it's also fair to say and correct me
if i'm wrong they certainly don't also
say that there's not a special pointer
so to me it seems like they're agnostics
as
not that they say there's not a special
pointer but there's they're agnostic as
to
whether there's a pointer or not well i
mean as you know the closest
that there is to such an indication is
from relativity where you can't uniquely
slice the universe into the present
moment right you have infinite freedom
in deciding what you mean by the present
once you go very far beyond your
current environment yeah but
that's that's just the concept
of simultaneity at different points in
space
and that's a very in my mind
unhelpful concept i mean one thing that
i think
the the lesson from special relativity
is in a way that
that we should probably get the rid of
the word simultaneity
but if you think only the present moment
is real you have to define what you mean
by the present moment
unless you have a fully local version of
what you mean by that which is a
slightly more radical ontological shift
the but what you were referring to
in terms of the relativity
of two points in time being arbitrary
depending on your
how you slice space time
that's comparing the present moment at
different points in space yes
so what i'm saying that's we both know
is
is dangerous yeah but
from defining at my own presence if i'm
not worried about anybody else's
perspective
um then defining my present now
you know i think is just whatever
my current state is by defining
that by a clock or by the state of
configuration of my atoms i know it's a
bit arbitrary but
i i realize it's a problem but well no
so i mean i think that is
along the lines of what i was thinking
of when i mentioned this very local
version
of what you mean by presentism i mean if
if naively if i say only the present
moment is real
someone's gonna say okay what is really
happening now on alpha centauri
and there's no answer to that but the
lesson is that it's a bad question
right right it's not that that's an
argument towards eternalism
do you by the way get into the
distinction between humanism and
anti-humanism about the laws of nature
do you know this distinction we
i talked about on the podcast with dan
hall and
uh roughly for the audience who for some
crazy reason hasn't listened to that
episode yet
humans believe that the world is just a
collection of things
that happens and we sort of uh
encapsulate them into what we call laws
of nature the patterns that we see in
those things
whereas anti-humans think that the laws
of nature
have some oomph to them they actually
sort of generate one moment from another
in a more
uh creative becoming way so it's a being
versus becoming kind of perspective and
i wonder if that maps on to your
feelings about
presentism and anti-humanism versus
eternalism and humanism yeah i'm
certainly not that familiar with
that dichotomy but i do
my perspective is that of course
everything that happens in the brain
is a direct directly governed or
directly constrained by the laws of
physics of course
now the brain evolved
to survive in a world governed by the
laws of physics right which is
at least of course our intuitions about
quantum mechanics are way off they're
horrible our intuition's about cosmology
our way off they're horrible
but our intuitions about the mesoscopic
newtonian physics are actually pretty
good
and if they weren't we'd be dead because
it's very important
to have those intuitions so in that
sense i think the brain
has to be governed
in one way or at least tuned or
calibrated to grasp the laws of physics
so i think hume
talks about cause and effect contiguity
and certain fundamental laws allow the
brain
or i don't know if we should call them
laws but i think he refers to them as
laws laws of contiguity or associativity
metaphysical principles of some sort
yeah um so i think the brain is built
in to is built to capture
those laws and and again we were just
talking about simultaneity right and i
and i was saying that you know i think
in many ways the lesson from special
relativity is that
the concept of simultaneity across
different points in space
is very unhelpful but the brain evolved
to pay a lot of attention to
simultaneity we're sort of addicted to
simultaneity right because
the brain was trained and i think this
is built in
to the brain if i see you moving your
lips
and hear your voice my brain concludes
that you are generating that sound but
if you're a ventriloquist and you have
a ventriloquist dummy on your lap and i
hear sound
and i see the lips of the ventriloquist
move of the
of the dummy move then i conclude the
sound is coming from the dummy and it's
a very compelling illusion so
your brain is continuously using
simultaneity between modalities between
events
to make sense of the world um so so i
think it does
confuse our interpretation of of of the
physics in some ways no i think that's
perfectly fair
and um let me run something by you
because i have this sort of half-baked
idea
uh that i don't i don't think i've ever
run by a real neuroscientist
about exactly this question how well can
the human
mind in principle do understanding the
laws of physics
given its manifold lack of capacity and
so my half-baked idea is that
at some point i don't know when but
roughly speaking
there was a phase transition in which
human minds became essentially touring
machines right
uh yes we have the inability to add big
numbers but
we know what it means to add a number
and there's no in principle maximum
number that we can add or anything like
that
we have it manifest image of the world
with folk physics where we think things
are solid and they exist in
three-dimensional space
but by doing experiments by coming up
with hypotheses
we can invent relativity in quantum
mechanics and all these things
so i i do think that obviously there's a
lot of
uh bugs as is in the the word in one of
the titles of one of your books
uh in our human brains that prevent us
from being perfectly reasoning machines
but i do think we've passed some
threshold where there's no reason to
think
that the ultimate laws of physics are
beyond us
yeah that's a deep question
i i struggle i don't struggle as much as
you
probably do with that but i struggle
with
the self-centered question of of
consciousness
can the brain understand consciousness
so you're asking is so
listen i mean at the end of the day
we're unusually smart apes right
and and i don't think we have any real
right to believe
that we have some right
to think that we have can understand the
universe or it can understand ourselves
that doesn't mean we can't but i think a
bit of humility here
is is is appropriate
so i think
that for the laws of physics i don't
here's here's
here's the way i would put it sean and
neuroscience is struggling with this
issue
neuroscientists agree that we want to
understand the brain
what neuroscientists don't agree on is
what it means to understand the brain
so the question i pose to you is you
said can we understand physics
i don't think physicists would
necessarily agree what understanding
means
so does having the equations comprise
understanding
and ultimately that's probably the best
understanding there is
or does it have understanding whether
a photon is a particle or a wave
or not what does understanding mean
and i think that's what we're really
struggling let me give you another
example
i we started off saying that we might be
at the phase and the interaction between
neuroscience and machine learning where
neuroscientists are should be learning
from machine
the machine learning field so in machine
learning they create these incredibly
sophisticated computational devices
based on neural networks that say kick
our ass
in chess so alpha zero just
destroys humans uh in the game of chess
do we understand how alpha zero
achieves that okay so it's a tricky
question right because
we know every single quote synapse of
that program all the weights all the
activity
and the algorithm that generated right
um but in a way we don't understand
how it generated that move or why it
played that move versus the other or if
it
made a move that happened to be wrong
how we would correct it so in one sense
we don't understand it
but another sense we know the equations
that created it
and ultimately you know i think it was
feynman that said
you know i can understand something if i
can make it yeah and i think that's a
very pragmatic use of the word
understanding
so my question to turn around to you
which was
if the human brain is able
or to understand the laws of physics
what does unders what does that even
mean sean what does understanding laws
of physics mean
well i think that's an excellent
question and it in part
sorry it's both an excellent question
and a
useless question because and the
useless aspect is that part of the
answer is going to be
carefully parsing different possible
construals of the word understanding
right because we use that one word to
mean different things
uh but i do think there's also a good
question lurking in there uh because
there are different aspects and knowing
what they all
are it's not like there's some right
aspect of understanding and some wrong
one
uh but there are different ones and we
can ask you know when we achieve
different levels of understanding
if we had perfect equations
that govern the fundamental stuff of
reality so we had some ontology
right some stuff that we said earlier
some representation mathematically
of what reality is and some equations
which we thought were 100 complete and
accurate in describing how it behaved
that is a kind of understanding which we
are nowhere near yet
but would certainly count as a kind of
flavor of understanding
and like you say it would leave us
completely unable to do a lot of things
that we would want
to do it's that's like having the
understanding at the
neuron level of uh of alphago or
something like that
we would also like as you say to have
some higher level understanding and
and maybe the best way to contemplate
that is in
once again this counterfactual sense you
know if you
so you know what all the weights uh in
the neural network are in alphago
but if you changed one what would happen
what would be the difference right
that's incredibly hard to understand you
basically start from scratch and just do
the whole thing
again so that sort of higher level
seeing the emergent patterns
understanding
would be lacking in that and that's a
perfectly good kind of understanding
also i'd be in favor of that
and there's probably other layers of
understanding that are relevant
this is part of why i'm an eternalist
and i don't think that it uh
conflicts with my personal feeling the
time flows then i can make choices that
affect the future and affect the past
and it's also a reason why i'm a
compatibilist about
free will uh i don't know what what is
your free will stance we should get it
on the table here for the audience
so i think the first lesson to be taken
from free will is really how much we can
debate something without properly
defining
what we mean right that's the amazing
thing about free will
and in the context of free will i'm
reminded of the
zen uh koan you know if
chief wasn't forest and no one's there
to hear it doesn't make a sound
right and it sounds deep but you know if
you say at the moment you define
sound it becomes silly if i define sound
as vibration of air molecules well of
course it doesn't make a sound
if i define sound as
those air molecules hitting my tympanic
membrane and
creating conscious perception of course
it doesn't
make a sound
so in free will my view is that if i use
my free will
to define free will as
the decisions my brain makes uh
conscious and unconscious
processes then of course i have free
will i
am my brain my brain is me um
so the decisions my brain makes at the
conscious and unconscious level
are is my free will now of course
if i define free will or if we define
free will as what i believe you've
referred to as libertarian
free will and which is somehow above the
laws of physics
then i think it's our scientific
obligation to say no there is no free
will
because we're scientists and and
things are everything should be obey the
laws of physics so we have to say
um no there's no free will so i think
when we're talking
about the concept it's a bit of what
some people have called crypto dualism
the question of itself is
a bias the brain has it's like the brain
evolved to make a mind that didn't
believe it was caused by the brain
yeah um so the mere question of free
will i think is
suspect because it somehow implies
that people are crypto dualists
right now i think that we're more or
less on the same uh
train here so so that's good but this is
what again i'll finish the thought about
why
this makes me completely happy with
being an eternalist even though my
immediate personal perception of time is
so different i think that
there is a fundamental layer to reality
i don't know what it is
i have my ideas i hope that people have
their ideas uh
but there's also numerous higher level
emergent approximate
descriptions of that and what's crucial
is that those emergent higher level
descriptions
capture something real and if if for no
other reason than purely
practical ones right i can know when i
see a table
if it's you know in someone's house that
is not trying to trick me or something
like that it's not like the amazing
randy's house so i'm walking into
a you know a pit of vipers but you know
he's trying to trick me
i know that if i put my coffee cup on
the table it will
um not fall through right it'll be
supported by that
now that does not necessarily rely on
the fact that i know the table is
really made of atoms and those atoms
really are
have fermions in them that obey the pale
the exclusion principle and the whole
thing is described by a quantum field
theory
obeying the laws of physics like all
that stuff who cares whether i knew that
or not
it is not an illusion for me to say oh
there's a solid
object here and i can put the coffee cup
on it because that captures something
predictable and real
right and i think that likewise my
perception that i exist in the present
moment
i make choices about what i'm going to
do in the future uh
all of that is very useful and practical
and real it's none of it is fundamental
but that's okay with me it's not an
illusion either and
as you said i think we're in large
agreement
about that i just feel
that ultimately the question of
the reality of nature and if the past
present and future
are equally real is something that we
should strive to understand about
the nature of the universe and i think
that as you said the current
your interpretation leans towards or is
eternalist but there's no empirical data
one way or the other at this stage
indeed it's not clear what the any
empirical data would look like
so i think if we try to be
um more objective listen
and we accept a lot of strange
counter-intuitive ideas in physics right
we accept um
entanglement um that clocks
slow down uh high gravitational
potentials and so forth we accept those
because
there's a ridiculous amount of
experimental data to support those
that's obviously not the case with
eternalism
um yet it's a strange idea intuitively
for most people that somehow the present
still persists or the future is quote
out there
in some way so in the absence of any
empirical data
for that it seems to me we should take
as a data point in the lack of any other
data points
trust our perception um so
i would just like to put that one data
point in there and i'm willing to throw
it away
if we get better data points sean but it
just seems that that should be the
tiebreaker for now
but i know yeah for what it's worth
i think that's perfectly fair and i
think as a final thought that will
encourage listeners in the audience to
try to go out there and construct some
closed time-like curves
and therefore prove you wrong i think
that would be a wonderful little project
for the mindscape audience
that would be that would definitely help
settle this debate and um so keep me
posted if any of your listeners do that
sean we will not keep it secret i
absolutely promise you so dean bonamano
thanks very much for being on the
mindscape podcast
thank you so much for having a
stimulating conversation sean
[Music]
you